[ MUSIC PLAYING ]
It feels like somebody's, like,
squeezing your heart.
That's how I felt.
Very gut-wrenching.
Just be prepared for lots--
lots of emotions.
The idea of shooting this film
came about in the beginning
of 2018.
We were all just kinda taking
a leap of faith.
We were all pretty, um,
what's the word?
skeptical I think
is the word.
I just didn't ever think
it was going to happen.
I was like, "Oh, yeah,
they're going to film me.
But, eh, they're not going
to make a movie, you know?
They're just gonna film
a bunch of ( bleep )
and they're never going
to actually make a doc.
Never going to actually, like,
put it out there in the world.
We're never going to see it."
But they did.
And they made a good one.
Really ( bleep ) emotional.
Oh, my God.
Let me start over.
When we first watched it,
we were in my living room.
I knew there was
some stuff in there
that I was going to be
mortified by.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
( bleep ) happened, so...
But I cried out of joy
for a lot of it
because I guess I didn't really
put together the fact
that it's gonna be
about my life
and how many things
I didn't know
anyone was paying attention to.
I never would have thought
that anyone
would be able to capture
exactly what was going on
in such a beautiful, like,
intimate way.
When we were halfway done
with the movie,
we just paused it and we called
my mom and dad at home
and we sat there, like,
all of us, we were just like,
"We love you.
You're such good parents."
It was-- I mean, I know they're
amazing parents,
it was just so beautiful
to see it.
I didn't get to really
appreciate how amazing they are
and always have been,
so I think that's--
that's the perspective
that changed a little for me.
We see things for how
we see them,
and Finneas, as my brother,
was talking about how
it was really interesting
for him to watch the movie
because he was seeing me
in a different perspective
than he's even seen before.
Oh, my God. Shut up.
He was telling me that there was
just certain things that are in
the doc
that he was like,
"That's not ever something
I've ever thought about, you know,
with you, but it's you."
Um, you know, they were filming
for so long,
that we got so used
to the cameras
that I don't remember when
a camera was or wasn't there.
I don't, like, close up
in front of, like, a camera,
which is, like, a blessing
and a curse, I think.
There's certain things
in the doc that I never planned
on sharing with the world.
There's a lot of stuff
that was very traumatic for me
that is in the doc
that I had to relive watching,
and it's kind of horrible
to think about
millions of people
having access to it.
But, it's good.
♪ I don't need a... ♪
I think it's cool for people
to see another side
that they didn't know was--
was there the entire time.
So I have to just hide that,
not just like-- I don't know.
I don't know. I'm nervous.
I'm very nervous.
Scared? I'm very scared.
- Man: You should be excited.
- Oh, God.
I'm very excited for the fans
to see this doc.
I've been, like, jumping
up and down about it.
I'm interested to see how people
react to certain things
in this movie
that nobody knew were going on.
You know, barely my family
even knew.
And know that the fans,
you guys,
you're the only reason I'm,
like, still right here,
so thank you
and I love you
and I'm so excited
for this journey.
And I'm excited to be with you
through it all.
Gotta watch this movie
on a big screen
and turn all the lights off,
get some blankets,
light a candle.
You gotta have somebody with you
to, like, squeeze
'cause so many--
so many moments, like--
yeah, get somebody to squeeze,
get someone to cuddle, like,
fuzzy blankets,
probably wear pajamas.
That's what we did.
Candle, lights off, big TV.